his new book is out where all books can
be acquired now for a week plus
playmakers uh this man's book uh is must
read so you should go
and buy it joining us here on the rich
eisen show once again is mike florio
happy monday sir i appreciate the
clarification i don't care if you read
it i just want you to buy it reading it
is optional buying it as mandatory
well uh you know what i i uh on friday
it's when i reached out to you um
because i i needed uh somebody who can
understand the legal aspect of
everything with desean watson now that a
football team has not only
um acquired him but gave him the best
contract in the history of the national
football league in terms of guaranteed
and guarantees and so on and so forth um
and and you with your knowledge of the
nfl and also uh
legal world perfect uh and i appreciate
you joining me here so that's my
preamble to basically start with the
browns on friday said that their legal
staff told them they could not
uh or should not reach out to any of
desean watson's accusers because
uh i guess i don't understand why so
i'll give you the floor on that aspect
of what we heard from friday well the
various people who addressed the matter
gm andrew berry in the press conference
that happened alongside deshaun watson
and coach kevin stefanski and then
ownership which
zoomed in two hours later and a lot of
people believe that they all should have
been there facing the music together
that the owner should have been their
elbow to elbow with deshaun watson at
his introduction to cleveland the
message from barry and from the haslems
was that the lawyers strongly encouraged
them to not talk to these people because
it would potentially interfere with the
criminal investigation so they hired an
outside investigator who did something
to secure sufficient information to
allow them to become comfortable with
the notion of adding to sean watson
despite these 22 civil cases that were
still pending and the grand jury
possibilities that obviously have since
resolved the first one was the
the key to
sparking the land rush between four
teams to try to get desean watson and
then there was another one
last week that kind of surprised
everybody but it went away almost as
quickly as it emerged and now he has
in theory a clean bill of health on the
criminal side but he's still got these
22 civil cases and
i don't know whether or not rich they
are
comfortable that he did nothing wrong
andrew berry was asked as the final
question on friday
do you believe there was no wrongdoing
and he didn't answer it and i think
anything other than yes we believe there
was no wrong doing
is quite possibly no i just don't think
they
i don't want to say they don't care
i just think they're not
really all that concerned about tracking
down a final answer they're concerned
about what happens going forward can we
trust him in cleveland are we going to
have similar issues here
and are we going to get past this at
some point get to playing football and
winning games and everyone's going to
forget about it
so i i think that
they didn't necessarily want to track
down every last detail
they just want to be comfortable that
moving forward it's not going to be
something that they're going to have to
deal with in cleveland as it relates to
potential new claims
but
what about the legalese about they
shouldn't contact you know and look into
so a team says that they did their due
diligence but didn't speak to anybody
who says otherwise uh about watson makes
no sense to me and there's a legal
reason for it well one thing they could
do
is read the transcripts of the
plaintiffs who have given sworn
testimony within the confines of the
civil actions now not all of them have
done that
so
at some point you run out of material if
the goal is to find out what every
specific person says
about desean watson and then you have
other resources available now again it
all depends on how good the
investigators are you talk to people
from the houston police department you
talk to other people in the community
you talk to people who know
these individuals who are
making these claims against desean watts
and you speak extensively
to his
team
and
lawyer rusty hardin has been on record
saying he thinks that
all of the women are not telling the
truth now i don't think he's come out
and said it's a conspiracy or
whatever and it's going to be very
difficult to hold a conspiracy of 22
individuals together for one year plus
if it is something like that but
yeah i i just think at the end of the
day they made an assessment that he's
got an issue in the civil justice system
that he has to resolve he's got an issue
with the league that's going to result
in a suspension at some point
but after all of that happens we move
forward with a franchise quarterback for
at least the next decade and we're fine
making that bet so that's why i think
deep down rich
that's why i say they didn't care and i
don't mean that they are uncaring i mean
they just don't care about the details
he's not going to be charged criminally
he's got to work out these civil cases
and the best thing they could do is tell
them just take some of this 230 million
dollars and settle the damn cases
they're doing this for the payoff not
for the short term they understand
there's going to be short-term pain
they're dealing with it
i don't know that they properly
estimated what they're going to be
dealing with but i think to get down to
it they just really didn't want to turn
over every rock and find out everything
and make their own judgment because if
they had determined he had done
something wrong
i still think they would have
done the deal they just want to know
going forward can they trust him not to
engage in the same behaviors again has
he learned his lesson that's the thing
that i think they wanted to know mike
florio of uh pft live on peacock uh
author of playmakers where all books are
sold pro football talk here on the rich
eisen show so moving forward with watson
he says he has no intention of settling
any of these cases so does that mean
that uh you know week six
you know big thursday night game sunday
night game or what have you
um
we could be getting ready for the game
and somebody
has a sit-down interview and they're
talking about it or
or we find out more information about
what happened i mean
this is an open situation it's not open
and shut so
just a few weeks ago that pete carroll
said he has no intention to trade
russell wilson and i don't say that
flippantly
when we say no intention intention
changes and i think part of this game
and and i don't want to trivialize it
but there is a certain
gamesmanship to it when you're dealing
with a lawyer who represents the 22
individuals who know that if the person
who's been sued shows excessive urgency
to settle the case what happens price
goes up that's the way it works people
look at that and say oh i thought it was
about justice and truth and no at a
certain point it's about
how much are you going to pay me to
settle this case and how much is it
worth to you to not have this cloud
hanging over you your employer and your
new nfl city so
if he says on friday i want to settle
these cases price goes up
so he tried to finesse it by saying no
intention to settle i want to clear my
name
that's the signal that his camp has been
sending they intend to go forward they
intend to fight they intend to prevail
and think about how the process is going
to go you're not going to try all 22 at
once you're talking about one after
another it's going to take half of a
year at least
to process these cases unless you're
doing two or three a week and maybe you
can i don't know but you're talking
about a lot of work a lot of effort to
go through 22 trials i think at the
right moment at the right time
they make settlement offers they come up
with a way to properly resolve these
cases jimmy haslam said he trusts that
desean watson's camp will do the right
thing and the one thing that i think
watson's camp needs to understand i'm
not sure that they did as of a week ago
maybe they do now
if there's 22 cases pending rich when
the season rolls around
there's a real good chance he's ending
up on paid leave
22 is too many one or two
what can you you know who can stop
anyone from suing anyone else for
anything you get to 22
you're at the point where
something happened that shouldn't have
happened here and we're not like gonna
let this guy play until these cases are
resolved you know to the extent that he
thinks he's gonna get suspended six
games and everything's gonna be fine
he may not play for a full year and then
next year he'd get suspended and then it
would be over so that's something he
needs to factor into his intention or
not to settle these cases so i guess uh
the follow-up to that before we move on
to a couple other items is what do you
think the commissioner's going to say
when he meets with the media a couple of
times over the next
several days at the uh the annual
meeting down in florida what do you
think he's going to say he'll basically
say what they said in their statement
last week these are serious allegations
that we continue to study very carefully
and
whatever question he gets asked he'll
recite some version of that and they'll
move on i i really do think that's what
will happen it's part of what he gets 65
million a year for
those four times a year when he's in a
press conference and the tough questions
come his way he finds a way
to to get through the minefield and move
on to the next topic so i don't think
we'll get anything new or any type of
revelation now you know the offseason
program starts april 19 for the browns
and they expect deshaun watson to be
there and in theory he could be put on
paid leave before then but the nfl
typically waits until football season to
do that kind of thing because if you put
them on paid leave then you make it a
big deal and more people know about it
this is ultimately a pr tool for the nfl
to take the heat out of the hot kitchen
and put the guy on paid leave so i think
they continue to
work
privately and i think they hope that the
case is settled so they can move on to
figuring out whether or not there's a
suspension
but otherwise to not make this a bigger
story than it is so you think it's
possible he gets on the commissioner's
exempt list until everything gets
settled and then
he'll get um he'll get suspended like
it's entirely possible this five-year
deal
that he might not play for an entire
first year of it like that i think it's
entirely possible that if 22 cases are
pending when august rolls around they
put him on paid leave and
i think that he needs to understand that
in no uncertain terms and once he does
that's when his no intention to settle
the cases will become every intention to
settle the cases but he's got to
understand what it means to fight and
even though there's not a price to be
paid because he still gets paid
the price is you don't get to play and
the nfl has always said they don't think
that's punishment of course it's
punishment i mean you want to give
anybody else a paid vacation from their
job 99 of the people out there would say
i'll take it but for football players
they want to do their job they want to
play especially after a guy sat out all
last year for different reasons but
similar
this year
he starts his time in cleveland with the
league saying you're on ice until these
22 cases are over if he knows that
then
he gets these cases settled i believe
mike florio here on the rich eisen show
possible that kaepernick gets a shot
here he was working out he's talking in
front of microphones we talked about it
last week um that that would be in my
mind the last piece of the wildest
offseason three-week period in the
history of the nfl is there any there
there on that front from what you're
hearing well back in 2020 post george
floyd when people had the epiphany that
colin kaepernick had a point in 2016
right right there was that ground swell
that recognition this is exactly what he
was talking about
it felt like if the window was ever
going to be open again it was going to
be open then and it felt like it was
open and there was a sense hey it's
finally going to happen and now here we
are two years later and i think he
wisely seized on what we all realized
early in the quarterback carousel
process that the supply was not going to
necessarily meet the demand and when you
had at least for a little while mason
rudolph is option one in pittsburgh and
you still have drew lock as option one
in seattle
if he's ever gonna get a chance it's now
but i think it comes down to the simple
fact that they've successfully frozen
him out for five years
and no one at this point and i don't say
this as a political observation i say
this as a pragmatic
business reality for the nfl given every
choice they've made for the five years
that colin kaepernick has been a free
agent
i don't think anyone
wants to even flirt publicly with colin
kaepernick because the minute you do
30 or so of your fan base loses their
minds
and
that's why he never got signed in the
first place and again that's wrong it
was wrong for them to collectively shun
him and he ultimately got between five
and ten million dollars from the league
for colluding to keep him out even
though he never did anything that
violated any rules i know that makes
people mad but he never did anything
that violated a single role of the nfl
but here we are now
and we know that that segment is out
there that is just ready to get
triggered and just ready to activate
what owner as a business matter
is going to say and is going to have as
i said last week on pft live the moral
and financial courage to do it none of
them do none of them do and i'm not
saying it's right or wrong i'm just i'm
like i've been following this leak for
50 years none of these owners will stand
up and do the quote unquote right thing
because they know it's going to cost
them money and it's going to create them
headaches oh man
i mean
if the guy has the ability to play it's
time absolutely well spin time richie's
been time think back to march of 2017
he becomes a free agent
and and what happened and i don't you
know i'm saying i don't want to piss off
any of my colleagues in the media but
never stops me any other time
how many people were peddling bs flat
out bs that was being parroted to them
by people in the league who were
scrounging for a way to justify not
doing business with colin kaepernick and
we heard all of these bs talking points
repeated over and over and over again
until you know and they're all
they're all flawed but it doesn't matter
if they're flawed what matters is the
fans out there that are anti-calling
kaepernick starts spouting that stuff
off and it turns into this big social
media
blender that you know you can support
any position you want to support so it
all started five years ago he should
have had an opportunity the moment he
opted out of his contract with the 49ers
they would have cut him if you know
people use that while he opted out he
could have stayed with the 49ers he
opted out it's his fault they were going
to cut him if he didn't opt out he just
wanted to get the free agency sooner
and so and and so this is five years old
this story has been hanging around
for half of a decade that's why i don't
see it changing all of a sudden what
what what out there that's happened
other than him doing a few workouts
and a couple of crappy quarterbacks
currently at the top of death charts
what else has changed
to bring it to the point where
we're going to reverse five years of the
nfl giving them the cold shoulder and
again i think it's wrong it's been wrong
from the inception
but i don't know what's changed to cause
what would be a dramatic shift at this
point mike florio here on the rich eisen
show um
before i let you go you just mentioned
how the 49ers once upon a time cut a
quarterback that took him to the super
bowl and kaepernick is that the option
in front of them about jimmy g right now
how come
is it the shoulder the reason why he's
not going elsewhere and or or just seats
have been
taken up what's the latest on on jimmy
garoppolo i wanted red flags the lore
for a team that would even entertain the
possibility of trading for him now john
lynch the gm of the 49ers said today
that
that they don't want to cut him
well no they want to get value for him
but here's the problem one year left on
his contract 25 million compensation
package he had shoulder surgery on his
throwing shoulder without even telling
the team he went and did it on his own
nobody knows when he's going to be
healthy
and the 49ers want to trade that
contract that 25 million dollar plus
salary charge and cap charge to another
team
that currently doesn't know what they're
getting meanwhile the 49ers are weighed
down by that 25 million cap charge they
could be using those dollars to resign
nick bosa debo samuel
so
it's a strange game of chicken i think
and you know the 49ers possibly
overplayed their hands before
the colts got matt ryan matt ryan falls
out of the sky
onto onto the colts and they're out of
the market and the saints decide to
stick with jameis winston and the
steelers option for mitchell trubisky
and there go the three possible
destinations for jimmy g via trade so
i think they're gonna have to cut him
and i think there's a good chance the
browns are gonna have to cut baker
mayfield those are the two names that i
think people are watching the most right
now and i think both of those guys are
eventually going to get cut because you
know at the end of the day rich even
without a no trade clause
if you have a franchise quarterback or a
guy that you want to be a franchise
quarterback and you're interested in
trading for him and he says i don't want
to play for you are you going to go
ahead and do that deal i don't think
you're going to do that deal
mike appreciate the two cents as always
thank you so much
hey man uh i really
nice good one we're talking to you same
here you be well let's uh let's do this
again soon
appreciate you saying that that's uh
mike florio at pro football talk
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here